between Ukraine sort of spinning out of
control between the economy deflating
between the fact that nobody thinks that
Biden is competent and all that stuff
well what are they going to do because
we got about three weeks before the
midterms what are they going to do
yeah you got it they're going to call us
racist when a Democrat says something
racist or anti-Semitic
we would we
we when a mega Republican says something
racist and or anti-semitic they are
embraced by cheering crowds and become
celebrated and sought after endorsements
Senator tuberville let's not forget this
just happened saying black people commit
crimes okay so first off no the
Democrats do not call out racism and
anti-Semitism ilhan Omar and Rashida
Talib are literally the two biggest
let's say Jew haters I don't like the
word anti-Semitism like they have an
obsession with that tiny little country
that Jews live in they don't care
whether hate crimes are up against Jews
and blah blah blah it doesn't fit into
the intersectional calculator the
Democrats they're the ones that are
importing all of the racism the
neo-racism of equity and making sure
that we discriminate against Asian
people and that people get jobs based on
skin color and all those things so they
are the modern racist the idea that
people are being applauded at Republican
rallies for saying racist or
anti-semitic things uh you did your
homework last night right did we find
any video on that we could not find any
videotape on that now we'll keep looking
for those moments where someone at a
republican rally says something racist
and is applauded she references
tuberville there saying that black
people commit crimes
um yeah you know it is true that people
of all colors commit crimes
um and sometimes that includes black
people so you know saying that say black
people are shooting black people in
Chicago and nobody cares about it
um that is not racist but every time a
republic you know they'll go crazy if a
white cop shoots a black person we can
burn down a city destroy Pep Boys take
it out at your local Target uh you know
if a black guy shoots 10 people in
Chicago you talk about that you racist